n Dubé, est avec nous
ce soir. Bonsoir, M. Dubé.
- Bonsoir.
- Vous êtes un homme
qui aimez l'efficacité,
Donc, combien de temps
vous vous donnez pour que
les patients puissent voir
vraiment une amélioration
tangible dans les urgences?
ministre de la Santé, Québec
- Quelques semaines.
Je voudrais qu'on voit des
premiers signes d'amélioration.
D'ailleurs, moi, j'en vois, là,,
dans la baisse de nos personnes
qui sont en attente d'une place,
par exemple, dans un CHSLDs urga
prendre quelques semaines, mais
ça se fera pas... ça se fera pas
partout pareil. Il y a desendro,
il y a des établissements
où ça va déjà mieux.
Et on est en traind'implanter ds
pratiques sur plusres.
C'est sûr qu'il y a des endroits
qui sont un petit
en retard que d'autres, mais,
globalemnse que
dans les prochaines semaines
on devra
capable de passer à travers
la période qui s'ede qui s'ede ,
d'ici les Fêtes.
- Prochaines semaines,moinsmoins
d'un mois, ou plus d'un mois?- a
des endroits où on va le voir
dans les prochaines semainesd'u.
globalement, on va avoir
beaucoup
dans nos urgences à cause
des Fêtes qui s'en viennent,
à cause
toutes sortes de raisons,
mais j'aimerais ça qu'on voit
des améliorations à très,
très court terme.
- Parce que l'heurc
vous l'ont redit, sont très
inquietsent d'un point
de rupture. Ils vous ont écrit
une lettre, là, dans laquelle
damnées à sacrifier
leur mission première,soit de ts
opportun les personnes
dont la situation est instable,
Comment vous recevez ça?
- Bien, premièrement, je l
rencontre demain matin. C'est
drôle parce qu'ils m'avaient
demandé il y a que
c'était avant tout ce débat-là.
it que j'ait que j'ait que j'ai,
je les vois demain matin.
Puis, je vous dirais que,
c'est que, eux, sont préoccupése
qu'ils donnent...
- Beaucoup, oui.t
très préoccupés par ça,
puis ce sont des professionnels,
alors, mon rôle à moi, c'est pas
de soignde leur donner des outir
qu'ils soient capable de bien
faire leur travail.
Alors, c'est pour ça que je
pratiques, parce qu'il y a
plusieurs hôpitaentententententt
les mêmes problèmes et
qui réagissent mieux, hein?
nos meilleurs, sur qui on peut
prendre ur améliorer
ça partout pareil?
- Vous avez parlé de l'Hôpital.
- Entre autres. Mais j'ai parlé.
Sainte-Justine pour les enfants,
c'est là qu'on a beaucoup de
problèmes à cause des nouveaux
virus respiratoires.
Puis ils se débrouillent
quand mdans cesdans cesdans ces.
Alors, c'est un peu ce que
je dis aux chefs des urgences
que je vais voir demain
trois mesures très claires
qu'on veut implanter partout
et on va vous donner les outils
pour diminuer cette pression-là
sur vos les regardles regardles,
les trois mesures.
La première : prioriser le 811.
Est-ce que c'est le même 811
qu'on co une version améliorée
de l'agence?
- En fait, on améliore le 811,
simple pour les gens. Quand
ils ne savent pas où appeler,
- Au lieu de se rendre
à l'urgence? C'est ça le bu
à l'urgence, parce que...
d'éviter que les gens y aillent
quand ils n'ont pa
aux urgences. Alors, là,
les gens commencent...
on en a parlé beaucoup
dans les
On appelle le 811.
Si vous savez pas quoi faire,
vont vous rediriger, notamment
enfants.
- Il y a plus de monde
pour répondre au téléphone?
on travaille mieux avec Québec.t
des téléphonistes qui étaient
disponibles sur Services Qué
pour qu'ils viennent nous aider,
en ce moment, là.
- Les cliniques avpraticiennes
spécialisées, ça, ça veut dire
les cliniques sans médecins.
- Voilà.
- Vous ae cet après-midi :
Ça fait longtemps qu'on aurait
pu mettre ça en place.
Qu'est-ce qui coinçait?
un culture, hein, de... puis,
c'est pas les médecins qui
l'empêchaient, mais il y a
un réflexe de dire : on a
bien j'aimerais ça revoir
le travail de l'in
Mais, à Québec, là,
j'en ai une clinique
fonctionne de façon autonome.
Ça fo.
Alors, quand les professionnels
dans la cellule de crise
qu'on ne le fait pas à
'ai dit :
"OK, allons-y." Alors...
Mais il y a une question
qu'il faut pas avoir peurd'utils
pour changer les choses.
avancer dans le décloisonnement
des professions.
- Donc, un changement de culà o,
tout à fait.
résumer : libérer
les lits d'hôpitaux pour amener
d'une place en hébergement.
Comment vous pouvez rassurer
les gens qu'ils vont êtrebien sé
à le faire en hôpital
- Bien, la première façon de les
rassurerit
déjà dans certains endroits
encore une fois, et ça se fait
dans les Laurentides, c'est
une orientation qui avait ét
donnée par le ministère en 2017.
Croyez-le ou non, c'est pas
i l'a appli l'a appli l'a applix
qui l'ont appliquée, comme dans:
"Ça fonctionne très bien."
Ils ont été capablans
leurs hôpitaux parce que lesgen,
et on est capable de libérer de.
Donc, encore une
fait de façon sécuritaire.
une question d'implantation.
Il y en a une bonne pratique,
là, qui les envo
à domicile, puis avec l'arrivéea
ministre, la nouvelle ministre,
les soins à domic
le Dr Deschênes, dans Verdun.
alors ce qu'on demande à Sonia,
c'est de donner les outils
pour ce qui est en
de se faire à Lanaudière
puisse être implanté partout.
- Donc, vous regardez les
histoires qui fonctionnent bien,
puis vous essayez de vous
en inspirer pour les mettreailÇe
de la cellule de crise, onenten"
- Bien, ils ont raison parceun s
indicateurs nous disaientlus grs
m'entendre rapidement, dans lesr
on.
Mais les trois mesures dont
ils peuvent les implanterc ou e,
alors c'est pas...
- Ils pe? Est-ce q? Est-ce q? Et
avoir de l'aide de ministè
- C'est exactement ce qu'on va
faire. Mais là, je voulais au
pour encourager, autant lesrofe,
qu'ils sont pas tout seuls
en ce moment. C'est ça, il faut.
- Quand vous dites
tout seuls", eux, ils se sentent
vraiment seuls en ce moment,
trouventest
le gros problème dans le systèms
le premier à le savoir aussi.
On a présenté un reportage hier
qui ont été formés à l'étranger,
qu'on retrouve tr
chez nous, au Québec,
pour les médecins de famille,
, on va les
recruter, on va les chercher.uez
à leur faciliter la vie, à faire
en sorte qu'ils décrochent
- La réponse, c'est oui. Puis,
une des
énormément confiance depuis
les deux années que je suisqui t
le président du Collègedes méder
la crise justement pour m'aider
dans ces mesures-l
décloisonnement des professions.
Et là, il a fait récemment, just
faciliter l'apport de médecins
passer à travers la paperasse
de tout ça.
- Bien, il est temps qu'on le
fasse. C'est des mesures, comme
partout. Alors, j'ai demandéudrt
de venir nous aider, comment
plus rapidement.- Bon, alors, o.
En terminant, on a appris cet
solidaire ni le parti Québécois
ne vont siéger à l'Assemblée
nationale parce qu'ils
Charles III. Comment
vous réagissez à ça?
- Bien, ils pourraient peut-être
en attendant. Je sais pas, là.
- Mais croyez-vous qu'ils
devraient avoir leur place
- Mais ça, je vais vous dire
j'en ai assez, moi, avec
la santé en ce moment, là.arti,
au premier ministre, aux lea
de régler ces choses-là.
Moi, j'ai hâte d
dire ça, parce qu'on a beaucoupu
une très belle collaboration
avec Vincent Marissal,
alors j'espère que ces choses-là